[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us
on the "Next Live Show."
I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong.
If you can't be here
in person this week,
we've got you covered.
To make sure you
catch everything,
we have six livestream
channels, including
this one, the "Next Live Show."
Let's kick things
off with insights
on this morning's keynote
from Google Cloud leaders
Aparna Sinha, group product
manager Kubernetes, and Quentin
Hardy, head of Editorial.
Great to see you both.
APARNA SINHA: Thanks
for having us.
STEPHANIE WONG: Quentin,
we were just here together
nine months ago talking about
the state of cloud computing,
and that wasn't very long ago.
What have you seen
that's changed?
QUENTIN HARDY: That's
cloud time for you.
Nine months equals a year.
And two things stick out.
One, obviously, new leadership.
We have a new leader
at Google Cloud.
And the first keynote
is very telling.
He's focused on customer-ready,
enterprise-ready products
and services, and
a wealth of them,
and customer testimonials
backing that up,
which is fun to see.
The other thing
is the products--
a wealth of products.
A year's worth of
products in nine months.
I'd like to just cite one
of them, the Cloud Services
Platform, which is
now called Anthos.
Last summer, when it was
launched, it was prospective.
It was going to be in alpha
and then beta very rapidly.
It's ready in nine months with
more features, and products,
and services within it
than we could imagine
having done this quickly.
Yay to your team.
And what this allows is for you
to create, deploy, update, run,
check, secure all these
applications on-prem,
in Google Cloud, on all the
clouds-- wherever you want.
Just take the asset
and make it grow
and make it live better
in a system that is open,
and secure, and aimed
at customer needs.
RETO MEIER: Now, Aparna,
you've been closely involved
in the creation of the
Cloud Services Platform,
or Anthos, now.
Based on what TK
has already shared,
it already does a lot, right?
But it's going to do even more.
So what will that look
like, and why should that
matter to our customers?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
Well, you know, great
computing platforms
don't just add features
or reduce cost.
Great computing
platforms actually
change the game entirely.
They give customers capabilities
that they've not had before.
And that's what Anthos is.
Anthos can be used, even
if you're not in the cloud.
So it can be used in
your on-prem data center
to give you a cloud-like
environment, cloud-like agility
and speed, but also cloud-like
control and centralized risk
management.
And it gives both your
operators and your developers
a level of visibility,
operational visibility,
as well as ease of use
for the developer that
is hard to find anywhere else.
And then if you do
decide that you're
going to use a
public cloud, Anthos
gives you what no one else
gives you, which is choice.
And it allows you to write
once and deploy your services
anywhere.
And that's what really
accelerates your business
success.
QUENTIN HARDY:
The reason we like
open systems-- yes,
it's a better way
to make more secure software.
It's better choice.
You get more velocity.
These are all great advantages.
There's an element of
self-interest here too, though.
By leaving it up
to the customer,
by giving them that
freedom and choice,
it compels us to
stay competitive.
We have to listen more closely.
We have to respond more quickly.
And if you have
locked-in customers,
it's kind of a recipe
for mediocrity.
APARNA SINHA: You know,
I think one of the things
that a lot of customers
like about the cloud
is that they don't have to
worry about all of the things.
They can focus on
the things that
are important to
them and things that
add value to their business.
So for example,
developers and engineers
can focus on differentiated
capabilities that are unique.
And the cloud takes
care of all the rest.
But why only in the cloud?
You know, this is
something that you
ought to be able to
do on-prem as well.
And that's what Anthos does.
It dissolves the layers that are
underneath the differentiating
pieces.
And those are managed by
cloud, by Google Cloud.
Or they're managed
automatically.
And that way, you
know, your business
can focus on
accelerating itself.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
It seems like it's
picking the workloads that
make sense for our customers.
Quentin, you mentioned
before we started
that modernizing and migrating
was another big keynote
takeaway.
How does Google Cloud's
integration with
and migration of enterprise
systems help our customers?
QUENTIN HARDY: Exactly what
Aparna was just saying,
why can't it do more?
And in this case, why
can't your data do more?
Why can't all that
hard work that people
established over decades--
learning their customers,
learning their market,
learning their products--
be taken to the cloud
or be empowered inside on-prem
systems and get new life,
get new power, find new
insights with ML and AI,
or by employing
other cloud services,
just refreshing all that,
and taking that legacy,
and using that as an insight
to move into the future?
STEPHANIE WONG: Speaking
of this focus on our users,
Quentin, what do
you think are some
of the most compelling
examples of learnings
that come with working
with our customers?
QUENTIN HARDY: You know
what's easy to do in tech?
Deliver a lot of complexity.
And some companies
love complexity
because it's kind
of like lock-in.
If you can get somebody to
learn all that complexity,
they'll never learn
anything else.
They'll be afraid.
You know what's hard?
Simplicity.
Simplicity on the back
end for the provider
is really tough,
because you've got
to consider a lot of use cases.
You've got to build
in a way that's
going to work for a lot
of different interests,
and people, and locations.
That requires a lot
of careful thought.
And you've got to have a
kind of empathy for what
the customer wants to do.
What does the
customer want to do?
The customer wants to do
the things it's good at.
The customer-- he or
she wants to proceed
with the things they've
learned in the market,
with the products
they're passionate about.
That might not actually
be container management.
That's something we're
passionate about.
That's something we do.
And in some ways,
this is economics 101.
Let everybody focus on
their comparative advantage.
We are freeing up customers.
We are giving them
that simplicity
so they can get
stuff out of the way
and just work on the problems
to serve their customers.
RETO MEIER: Aparna,
Quentin's been talking
a lot about business folks.
But what does this
mean for the operators
and the developers who are going
to be using this technology?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah.
Well, like I said,
it's a game changer
for the operators
and the developers.
I would say there are
three kind of big changes.
Number one is the right
ones deploy anywhere.
For developers,
it means that you
can focus on the things
that add differentiation
to your business.
For the CIO, it means,
actually, that you can really
concentrate your talent.
You don't fragment your talent
across multiple different code
bases, across multiple
different types of tools.
And if you think
about it, you know,
every customer I've talked
to always says, the talent
is the most scarce resource.
Particularly, engineering
talent is really hard to hire.
It's really hard to keep
the talent motivated.
And I think the
reason creators are
excited about Anthos is, again,
for the same reasons, right?
Because they also get access
to a multi-cloud platform.
They also get access to the
benefits of something that's
at a level that they can
differentiate their code
and don't have to worry about
the underlying infrastructure
pieces.
STEPHANIE WONG: Quentin,
Google CEO Sundar Pichai
was an important part of
the day 1 keynote as well.
What did his presence
say about how
Google sees the cloud industry?
QUENTIN HARDY:
Well, obviously, you
bring out the CEO of Google,
he's putting the stamp on it
that this is big.
And you can't say that enough.
And this gets kind of to an
abstract reality of where
we are right now in the world.
There are four
major players, five.
You could go to six.
$5 to $10 billion in Capex each.
This is a very big
stakes operation.
Because this is the
infrastructure of the future.
As much as you think about
airports, or highways,
or deep water ports, or
telephones and telegraphs,
in their time, this is the
infrastructure of the future
that we are building and our
competitors are building.
We're building it with a certain
spirit we've talked about today
we think will give the
customers the most power,
give individuals of any size-- a
small company, a large company,
freelancer, you name it--
greater energy, greater
power, greater freedom
to realize what they
want to do in the world.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you
so much for joining us
again and sharing your insight.
QUENTIN HARDY: It's
great to be here.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you.
Thanks for having us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]